apprendre en s'amusant ce mardi 9
février 31 élèves du collège jean jaurès
de poissy ont pu tester un jeu de
société sur le thème de la défense
l'événement était organisé dans le cadre
d'une journée d'information sur les
enjeux de la citoyenneté
la partie dure en moyenne deux heures il
est très ludique en fait les élèves
jouent en collaboration pour contrer les
menaces est vraiment un jeu où ils sont
tous en équipe et ils vont avoir
différents rôles par exemple il va avoir
le rôle du président ou le rôle des
interventions qui va décider où les
françaises doivent intervenir
donc ça leur montre vraiment les moyens
que la france dispose pour contrer les
menaces et les menaces existantes dans
le monde entier une heure de
concentration et des changes premières
réactions de ses élèves de 3e sur ce
tout nouveau juge ça change des cours
classiques sens et interactif et bah ça
nous change de d'habitude je le trouve
bien stratégique faut réfléchir vous
parler avec ses camarades pour choisir
les choix à faire ce rendez vous était
une grande première pour le collège jean
jaurès de poids si ça répond à des
questions et ça vient en complément
voilà de ce conte faire en classe
notamment en éducation morale et civique
où on a un cours sur la défense
nationale et sur toutes les dimensions
citoyenne lire aux valeurs de la
république
la journée s'est prolongée par d'autres
jeux sur les métiers de la défense et de
la mémoire chaque semaine des
interventions sur le lien armée nation
sont organisées dans les collèges
yvelinois